[Music]
dj khaled crushed his set inside Maxim's
Hot 100 party Saturday night in LA but
first he hit the red carpet I'm
definitely the hot 100 you're saying
like you know Sam I'm on top of the list
number one another one the only one okay
major Keeler I got the song of the
summer got songs with the S shining
and Wow tops wild thought is like so big
Wow when I was just working with Rihanna
it's the most incredible thing ever
um shooting a video to make the record I
feel like it's gonna be one of my
biggest records ever Rihanna we did it
when I would sure like it is Wow Wow
Wow you know Rihanna an aside I had a
little moment at the video shoot and I
was I was proud of my son I mean my son
has a scene in his eye you're saying
that I've seen it and Rihanna's I like
you know they caught a moment so I'm
proud of my son nothing Assad is
incredible he's doing good he's eight
months old and he's my biggest blessing
he's my inspirations my drives my life
and everything's for my son he's an
executive producer he's a boss he's at
dawn he's a legend he's an icon and he's
the greatest that ever did it that's
good
[Music]